this is Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski we
are watching Grandmaster vladislav
kovalev Take On The World Champion
Magnus Carlson at the 2022 fide World
splits championship and a little
discussion there
between the Arbiter and of vladeslav
who's leaning back and now plays E4
another world champion still not in his
seat and the time control for the feed a
world Blitz it's three minutes per side
with a two second increment it's pretty
unprecedented
for one of the opponents not to be at
their chair when the game begins Magnus
Carlsen does like to be fashionably late
15 seconds have already elapsed you can
see Kobe over there waiting in
anticipation
for the opportunity to play the world
champion he is nowhere to be found 30
seconds now creeping down on his clock
while you're still sitting in the same
spot he's played one E4
now maybe Carlson is simply deciding
what opening he wants to play but you
know there's a time for Preparation and
there's a time for playing 35 seconds
and you can see those playing diagonally
in front of one of them looking back I
think that might be Fabiana carwana
where is the world champion
someone's running to his chair
that appears to be you yangi's opponent
who was 50 seconds late what happened
was there traffic in uh the tournament
Hall so there was one guy who was late
Magnus Carlson still hasn't shown up one
minute has passed this is getting crazy
and the craziest thing of course is that
Magnus Carlson could still very much
play a good game with only you know 20
or 30 seconds left on the clock but that
would be absolutely crazy kovanov has
not changed his sitting position at all
this entire time now it's a minute and
20 seconds now Magnus might have
confused the starting time of the round
that's happened before
but the starting time is usually
announced before the previous round is
is started so everybody else seemed to
know when the round was starting 90
seconds now off Magnus Carlson's clock
that's over half his time
what I love is that he has not changed
his sitting position at all he's
scanning the tournament hall for the
world champion and of course he does not
want to win a game by forfeit that would
be a lame way to beat the world champion
he wants an opportunity to play a Blitz
game with him you can kind of sense the
disappointment on his face
there's only a minute left on the world
champions clock his chair is left
unoccupied this is crazy I've never seen
anything like this now under a minute
he's got under a minute to run to his
chair and start playing 2 000 years
later there he is there he is the world
champion has arrived he's running chair
it's
at least on
um and uh oh my goodness he's running up
to the podium he has to find his board
he's got about 40 seconds before he
loses the game he is running in a Mad
Dash and he makes it he's got 30 seconds
on his clock and still time for a
handshake and he sits down and he plays
one E6 so maybe he was choosing an
opening this whole time you know that
would be pretty interesting 31 seconds
on Magnus Carlson's clock as he plays
the French defense and kavali of takes
on D5 which is a decision I already
don't like he plays The Exchange trench
which is a pretty easy opening for black
to Blitz out the moves in something like
Knight C3 or maybe the advance would
have forced Magnus Carlsen to slow down
instead Cavalia with an early C4 that
often leads to an isolated Queen Pawn
structure if of course black takes on C4
but Magnus Carlson delaying that move
he's already built up 35 seconds to his
clock and cavalia's time Advantage has
shrunk down to a measly two minutes
as he contemplates his next move he can
push the C Pawn down to C5 and Chase
Black's Bishop away Carlson seems a
little bit flustered but he's playing
the opening pretty decently thus far
Knight C3 Bishop B2 a lot of moves
possible and it's actually not easy to
handle a Time Advantage as big as the
one that kavaliev has because you're
feeling the pressure to win the game
quickly but Carlson can play well with
five seconds on his clock and Cavallo
has already spent a minute this is what
move four move five he finally decides
to bring his Knight out to C3 Carlson
just ignores the threat on the D5
quantity castles if white takes on D5
that pawn is going to be a Sitting Duck
and it can be pretty easily recaptured
by Black's other Knight which will go to
D7 and then to B6 and once black
recaptures the pawn on D5 he's gonna
have a very nice blockading Knight to
immobilize White's isolated Queen Pawn
on T4 and another 20 seconds spent by
Cavalia this is maybe even crazier than
Carlson's late arrival time cavallev
cannot decide how to to position his
pieces maybe C5 I think they moved
Bishop F1 to E2 just a modest developing
move could be the way to go his time and
Advantage is now under a minute maybe
he's being nice to the world champion to
equalize the playing fields and he does
take on D5 covers the check with a rook
and there goes Magnus Carlson's Knight
he brings it to D7 he adjusts some
pieces before pressing the clock he is
absolutely unconcerned he does have more
time than he started with
but of course he did start with 30
seconds Cavalli of Castle's kingside and
Carlson more piece adjusting as he plays
H6 preventing white Stark scored Bishop
from reaching G5 and maybe Cavalia
should have played Bishop G5 on the
previous move when he still had a chance
now the dark Squad Bishop doesn't have
all that many good developing spots he
can bring it out to E3 but then Carlson
will recapture on D5 and the bishop
Bishop on E3 will be under attack I
actually think the world Champion's
position is excellent here he's going to
win The Pawn on D5 he's going to get a
nice block hitting Knight on D5 and
Cavalia is trying to gain activity for
his other pieces with Knight to E5
Carlson ignores the Knight he takes the
pawn on D5 and maybe after a trade
Cavalia should try to position his light
squared Bishop on F3 to chase the Knight
away from D5 but Carlson could support
it with the Bishop from C8 which could
go into E6 or from the pawn which could
move from C7 to C6 no question of
Black's position is probably already
slightly better and look at the time the
time situation is almost equalized this
is on unbelievable kovalev has spent a
total of two minutes on the first five
or six moves and he now has 30 seconds
himself they're basically playing a
hyper bullet game with increment and
Carlson does indeed push the pawn up to
C6 and protects his Knight on T5 and if
I'm cabal if I'm trading pieces on D5 he
doesn't he brings his Queen out to B3
putting more pressure on the world
champions Knight
and now he does threaten to capture on
D5 three times Carlson leans back in his
chair and now he's finally begun taking
the very little time that he has left 15
seconds now on the clock and he brings
his own Queen up to B6 offering an
exchange of queens and Cavalia instead
takes the night we're going to see a lot
of exchanges the Queens are going to be
taken off the board very likely by white
or potentially even by black or white
could take on D5 twice 10 seconds now 10
seconds for cavallibus he takes on D5
and he does not grab the pawn instead he
exchanges the Queens but getting an end
game against Magnus Carlson where the
world champion has the bishop pair is
not a very advisable idea three seconds
three seconds work of olive as he brings
his Bishop out
crazy that he is the one who has to make
the moves for fear of losing on time
Carlson was still with 15 seconds on the
clock as he chases cavalia's only active
piece out of the center and he's gonna
bring his light squared Bishop
presumably to F5 he could also bring it
to E6 in order to secure the isolated
Queen Pawn first he brings his Rook up
to A4 and he attacks the D4 pawn and now
he attacks the Knight and the Knight is
no good spots to go one second
escobalife has to bring it all the way
back to E1 and A3 was a big mistake
Carlson pushes his beep on up to B5 and
now brings The Rook to C4 he's
threatening the move B4 Cavalia is
getting tortured here he is getting
massacred on the queen side and the
Bishops are off the board Cavalia was
able to defend the B2 Pawn
and now Carlson starts expanding on the
king side this is what the world
champion does he does not let you
breathe in these sorts of end games and
he has positioned his Pawns in an ideal
setup restricting white king and Knight
as much as possible the Knight can't
move to D3 because you lose the D4 upon
it can't move to C2 because you lose the
B2 Bonzo cavallup has to basically sit
around and wait he is trying to improve
the position of his Knight a great job
getting the Knight into the center and
chasing Black's light squared Bishop
away but Carlson is walking his King
ever so gradually over to the queen side
kc6 and King B5 and eventually something
is going to give Cavalia was still with
six seconds on the clock Carlson going
hither and thither trying to Chisel his
way into White's position The Rook is
currently parked on A4 he has to keep it
in contact with one of White's pawns no
he brings it up to A1 and whites Rook
does not have any active prospects but
Rook D1 by Cavalli of keeping the gates
to White's Queen side shut and there
goes Carlson's beep on he continues
grabbing space and strangling White's
pieces kavaliev is just sort of staying
put and bringing his King up to D3 where
it almost gets checkmated by the bishop
a check on B5 driving the king back to
C2 now King B3 is a big threat that
would win the B4 pawn and Carlson brings
his Bishop just in time to C4 the king
moves up to B1 Chasing The Rook away but
the Rook can go to the other side it can
go to h8 it can go to E8 it attacks the
Knight the Knight moves no it takes the
bishop oh but this looks bad for Cavalia
look at Carlson's pawns on C4 and B4
cavali was shaking his head the world
champion might win this game Rook D4
attacking Black's pawns and King C5
there might be D6
so Carlson pushes B3 and takes the pawn
on F3 takes the pawn on D5 he is now up
upon the king is chasing The Rook off of
the B file and Rook F4 offers an
exchange of Rooks the pawn end game
would obviously be lost for white
because he's down upon and the King bro
is brought back down a D4 this is
exquisite end game technique by the
world champion he threatens to take the
other Pawn on G4 two seconds for Cavalli
if he is desperately trying to defend
and he loses the second Pawn on G4 he
does pick up the pawn on B3 but Carlson
now has connected pass pawns which are
rumbling down the board kavali has to
set his own Pawn in motion
but it's not fast enough and it's
blocked by blackstruck and he resigns
the game what a display by the world
champion who started the game with only
30 seconds on his clock and what a
frustrating defeat for his opponent the
world champion wins another crazy one
and if you enjoyed this video make sure
to click the link in the playlist for
more of these Blitz videos thank you so
much for watching
[Music]